allow me to say that the spacex launch
of human beings to orbit on may 30th
was seen by many as the first step in a
new era of human space exploration
these human space flight missions were a
beacon of hope to me and to millions
over the past two years as our world has
been going through one of the most
difficult periods in recent human
history
we saw we see the rise of division fear
cynicism and the loss of common humanity
right when it is needed most so first
elon let me say thank you for giving the
world hope and reason to be excited
about the future oh it's kind of you
saying
i do want to do that humanity has uh
obviously a lot of issues and and uh
you know people at times do do bad
things but
you know
despite all that um you know i love
humanity and i think we should
uh
make sure we do everything we can to
have a good future and an exciting
future and one where that maximizes the
happiness of the people
let me ask about uh crew dragon demo two
so that that first flight with humans on
board how did you feel leading up to
that launch were you scared were you
excited what's going through your mind
so much was at stake
yeah no that was extremely stressful no
question
we obviously could not
um
let them down in any way um so
extremely stressful i'd say
uh to say the least
but we did
i was confident that at the time that we
launched that
no one could think of anything
uh at all
to do that would improve the probability
of success
um and we we racked our brains to think
of any possible way to improve the
probability of success we could not
think of anything more and and nor could
nasa and so
that's just the best that we could do so
then we we had
we went ahead and launched
now i'm not a religious person
um but i nonetheless got on my knees and
prayed before that mission
were you able to sleep
no
how did it feel
when it was a success first when the
launch was a success and when they
returned back home or back to earth
there's a great relief
yeah
it's for high stress situations i find
it's not so much elation as relief um
and um
you know i think once
as we we got more comfortable and proved
out the systems because you know we
really
um
you know you've got to make sure
everything works um
i was it was definitely a lot more uh
enjoyable with the subsequent uh uh
astronaut uh missions and i thought the
the inspiration mission was was actually
very inspiring um the inspiration for
mission um i'd encourage people to watch
the
inspiration documentary on netflix it's
actually really good
um
and it really isn't so i i was actually
inspired by that um and i i i so that
one i felt i i was kind of able to enjoy
the the actual mission and not just be
super stressed all the time so for
people that somehow don't know it's the
all civilian first time
all civilian out to space out to orbit
yeah it was the high i think the highest
orbit that uh in like i know 30 or 40
years or something the only one that was
higher
was this one shuttle sorry a hubble uh
servicing mission
um and then before that it would have
been um apollo in 72.
it's pretty wild
so it's cool it's good you know i think
uh as you know
as a species like we want to be
you know continuing to
do better and and reach higher ground
and and like i think it would be tragic
extremely tragic if um apollo was the
high watermark for humanity you know and
that then that's as far as we ever got
um
and it's um
it's concerning that here we are um
49 years after the last mission to the
moon
and it's almost half a century
uh and we've not been back
um and that's
that's worrying it's like is that
does that mean
we've peaked as a civilization or what
so
like i think we got to get back to the
moon and build a base there you know a
science base i think we could learn a
lot about the nature of the universe if
we have a proper science base on the
moon um you know like we have a science
based in antarctica and you know many
other parts of the world
and
um so that that that's like i think the
next big thing we've got to have like a
serious like moon base um and then get
people to mars and
you know get get out there and
be a space faring civilization
you